reformas económicas y el alza de los
precios de los combustibles fueron unos
de los detonantes de las protestas que
se extendieron por gran parte del
territorio ecuatoriano
en quito miles de manifestantes
convocados por organizaciones sociales y
sindicatos demandaron que el presidente
guillermo lasso revierta sus medidas
sobre el combustible que han llevado a
encarecer los productos básicos en el
mes de mayo del 2021 como resolución le
exhortamos al presidente de la república
que toque en el precio de los
combustibles pero en el 10 de mayo
cuando estaba a un dólar 55 el diésel no
190 como ahora congela el precio de los
combustibles el descontento se extendió
por todo el país en donde múltiples
carreteras fueron bloqueadas acciones
promovidas por varias comunidades
indígenas ecuatorianas no hemos tomado
colectivamente frente a las nuevas
medidas económicas que cada vez nos
tiene
dominados a nuestras poblaciones a
nuestros transportistas y a nuestras
comunidades
según el centro operativo de emergencia
nacional los bloqueos afectaron a 24 de
las provincias del país y el presidente
hizo un llamado a despejar las vías
ecuador es un país de comercio cierre de
vías y las paralizaciones afectan los
intercambios de bienes productos y
servicios que cada día reactiva en
nuestra economía dile no al paro al
descontento colectivo se le suma la
aparición del mandatario en los papeles
de pandora que han llevado a cuestionar
la integridad del lazo por diferentes
sectores de la sociedad ecuatoriana